FEMALE SPEAKER: Please.
[APPLAUSE]
Which.
Before I say any more,
we can flip the switch
to give you a little teaser of
what this amazing show is all
about, in case you
haven't seen it before.
[APPLAUSE]
That gives me goosebumps just
to see that teaser video.
Cavalia was the first show
that was produced and toured
the world.
Over four million
people have seen it.
The images that
you are just seeing
are from Odysseo, the
second production,
which, as we'll hear,
is quite different
from the original production.
So to maybe kick
it off, Normand,
where did this idea
of Cavalia come from?
How do you take it from
your imagination to reality?
NORMAND LATOURELLE: Yeah,
well, where it's coming from,
I was one of the co-founders
of Cirque du Soleil.
And when I moved out
of Cirque du Soleil,
I wanted to do
something different.
And so I created a show--
I'm from Montreal, Canada,
the French part of Canada.
And I created a show that
requires a few horses as extra
over there in Canada.
And there was an outside
show in the summer and so on.
It was not a horse show.
It was not a show about horses.
It was a show about
French Canadian tales.
And there was a
lot of performers,
120 performers on stage.
And at one point, when the
horses were coming on stage,
not doing a lot, just
riding across the stage,
people were looking at the
horse, not the performers.
So that attracted my attention.
I said, that's very interesting.
So my director at that time--
I did not direct that show.
The director at the time
came to me and said,
we've got to get
rid of this horse.
He's stealing focus.
Of course, this is where the
first bell rang in my head.
I said, if he's
stealing focus, it's
because-- in French,
we say "une bete de
scene," "a beast of stage."
The translation is
not totally good,
but you might get
the principle of it.
So when we say an
actor is stealing focus
from the other actor, we
call him a bete de scene.
He's a beast on stage.
So I said, we should
get more horses instead
of getting rid of the horses.
So I started to buy horses,
because in Canada obviously,
probably because of the weather
we don't have a lot of horses.
And it's getting very
cold during the winter
so we have to have it inside.
You cannot leave
the horse outside.
So we didn't have any
performing horses.
So I had to buy horses to
add more horses to the show.
And this is where the
idea started to grow up.
And when I got myself the
proud owner of 12 horses,
I said, well, maybe I should
do a little more than just one
horse one show
during the summer.
And this is where I
started to have the idea,
so maybe we can do something
artistic with the horse.
So how?
And this is where I
get very excited, is
how I can, like we
did with Cirque,
reinvent something or invent
something that doesn't exist.
And this is where
I got very excited.
Of course, my basic was, can
we have animals in the show,
having animals that
could be happy, which
was a big concern for myself.
And because I
didn't know horses,
obviously, I had
to explore a lot.
It took me a long time.
Took me almost 10
years from the idea
to the first show of Cavalia.
And I just wanted to
make sure that if I
bring a horse to a show,
they would be a happy horse.
And that was the entire
challenge of creating Cavalia,
and that's why Cavalia
became so popular.
Because when you get to
see Cavalia, of course
there is horses.
Of course there
is acrobat music,
special effects,
lighting, but most likely,
you see happy horses.
And you see a real bond between
the trainer and the horse,
and the artist and the horse.
And that is the
signature we had.
So after I created Cavalia--
that's a long answer-- after we
created Cavalia
in 2003, I thought
I did not push enough the
integration of the performing
arts into the horse world.
So I just wanted to create
something bigger, and also
as a touring show.
I created Odysseo in
2011, and this is the one
that is now here in San Jose.
But you don't need to be a
horse person to enjoy the show,
because there's a lot, a
lot of special effects.
It's a huge production.
It's one of a kind.
And obviously, I don't think,
as a touring show again,
it's comparable to any of
the best permanent shows
that you can witness
in Las Vegas,
because of the quality
of the production.
I just wanted to push
what could be achieved
on a tour production-wise.
So the lights are very modern.
The projection, we have
3D image projection.
We have a screen that is about
three times an IMAX theater
screen.
And it supports what I
call the first and only
6D show in the world.
I know I'm at Google here, so
I better be careful what I say.
But why is it 6D?
I wanted to explain
that, if I may.
Because the stage is very deep,
and we use the stage as layers.
So the first image you
have when you see the show,
you see a forest.
And then the forest disappears,
and then you see a mountain.
It's a real mountain.
Peaks are about 33 feet high.
And behind the mountain, you
have that gigantic screen.
And in between the
screen and the mountain,
you can see horses appearing.
And you feel like
you're watching
one of the most beautiful
Hollywood movies,
but you're there, alive.
And the projections
are so great.
They are HD projections,
3D, but very big.
So you feel the deepness
in the production.
So that's why I say it.
You have the 3D live
in front, and then you
have the 3D projection
in the back.
So three plus three?
Here, you are 6D.
Yes, I have the first
6D show in the world!
FEMALE SPEAKER: If anyone's
here from virtual reality,
maybe be taking some notes.
So on that subject of
technology, out of that vision,
what is the hardest to actually
stage in a live setting?
NORMAND LATOURELLE: Well,
when you do a big production,
a big show, whatever
type of show,
you run most likely
a show with a clock.
And then you have a
timecode, and a timecode
to run the music.
And then you know the
length of the show.
Cavalia, both
Cavalia and Odysseo,
we never know how long
it's going to last,
because we are with animals.
And the animals, pretty much for
half of the show, they're free.
When I say free, it's they have
no bit, no saddle, no ropes.
They just can go wherever,
and the stage is huge.
The stage is about twice
a hockey rink stage.
So it's huge.
So if a horse decides
to go, he goes.
And if he decides not to
come, he doesn't come.
And if he decides not
to leave the stage,
he doesn't leave the stage.
So all the cues are
managed manually.
We have a stage manager
that has thousands of cues.
But in addition,
she has to watch.
We also have the live musicians.
They have to watch.
Because if the horse doesn't
do what we wish he will do,
which happens often, and
that's the moment I prefer,
because they express themselves.
And then have to have a
show that is flexible.
And even with this
show supported
by a lot of technology--
I was talking
about the images, and the
lights, and everything,
and the special effects,
whatever you bring there,
need to be called one by
one by humans, because we
have to follow the horse.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I don't
think I've ever heard
of a show that has no end.
NORMAND LATOURELLE: That's true.
After every show, I look.
I'm not there at every show, but
the stage manager makes a stage
report, and the show
varies from 5 to 10
to 15 minutes at every show.
There's a lot of improvisation.
And coming back to
what I was saying,
my goal was to
have happy horses.
So first people can say
a horse is an animal.
It shouldn't be on stage.
But what I learned
through my search--
because I didn't know
anything about horses.
I just repeat that
because it's very true.
I could barely see a difference
between a cow and a horse
20 years ago, to
tell you the truth.
I'm a guy from the
city, you know?
I'm not a guy from the country.
Yeah, you go in front of a
field, you look at a horse,
you look at a cow and say,
oh, they're two animals.
They're very happy.
But when you go closer,
and when you start to look,
they are domesticated animals.
If it wouldn't be for human
intervention in the horse
world, they wouldn't
exist anymore,
because they were
surrounded by predators.
And so the horse, the
breeds we have today,
are man-made, like dogs.
You know, all the dogs,
there's no wolves in our house.
The horse is the same thing.
And all the horses, all the
breeds have a speciality.
They have a purpose.
So if you start to
describe, like here we
have a lot of the
American quarter horse,
they're made for cutting
and for going to the field
and bringing the cattle.
Yeah, cattle horses.
And then you have the horse
that does jumpiing competitions.
And that's what
they do-- they jump.
But those horses, they have
a different conformation
than the quarter horse.
And then we have a lot of what
we call the Spanish horses,
or the Iberian horses, which
are made by the Spanish
or the Lipizzaner is
the same from Russia.
Or you have the same
from the Lusitanos,
which are from Portugal.
They were made for war.
And also the Spanish made
them to pull carriages,
but an aristocratic carriage.
Am I OK with the English?
And then so you
see those what we
call the Spanish horses,
very elegant horses
walking like this.
So all the horses have
been created by men
for those specific purposes.
What is fantastic about
Odysseo and Cavalia
and what is fantastic
about how stupid
I was to think that I
brought to the horse world
different types of horses
doing different types of stuff
and I put them all in one show.
Where, if you go to a horse
competition or a horse
show, all day long, if you
see a jumping competition,
all day long, you'll see horses
jumping, after one, two, three,
four, five, you'll
say, OK what else?
I was not there for
doing a horse show.
I was there for doing
performing arts with horses.
So I do have horses that
jump, horses that dance.
We do have horses
that do what we
call "at liberty," where they
just play with their trainer.
And it created a world apart.
That's what is Odysseo
and through Cavalia also.
We definitely created something
that didn't exist before.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And when you
see it, it is so spectacular.
And you see these horses doing
their performance seamlessly.
But I'm sure there
are some breeds
or some horses
with personalities,
or they have their own quirks.
Are there some that are harder
to train, easier to train?
NORMAND LATOURELLE: Yeah, I
mean, they're like humans.
Or they are like anyone
living on this planet.
They don't learn at the
same speed between them.
They don't behave the same way.
And sometimes, we
could have horses
that we could buy
very expensively.
We train them.
We bring them to the tour.
And after a couple
of months, we say,
this is not his cup of tea.
And we just remove him.
Because these horses,
you always have
to look at a horse or any animal
the way they behave in nature
to see if they are
comfortable or not.
And horses are surrounded
in nature by predators.
We are a predator for the horse.
So he can get very scared.
But the moment you
give him comfort,
if you don't hit him,
if you don't beat him,
if he don't push him too
hard, if you tell him slowly,
or if you follow the way he
is to learn what he has to do,
he'll be more than pleased.
He will give you 10 times more.
But some horses come.
They achieve that.
They're good.
They're ready to go in the show.
And they arrive in front of
2,000 people and they say, oh.
Why am I here?
And that happened.
And after a month
or two, if we feel
that the horse is just
scared and gets very nervous,
we just remove him.
We just say, OK,
this is not his.
And other horses,
it's very fantastic,
because they don't
behave the same if they
are in public or not in public.
They are really stars.
They wait for the applause.
And if they have no
applause, this is boring.
I am telling you.
It might sound silly,
but this is how they are.
They have emotion.
The horses we have like what
they do, and they live--
and it's very important.
They live in herds.
And when you visit
the stable, they
are always in the same position.
They always have
the same neighbor.
So they're very social animals.
And when they come
on stage, we make
them feel that the stage
is not the place to work.
It's a place to play.
Horses, they like two things
in life-- they like to eat
and they like to play.
And so if you give them
food and then you bring them
to a playground as
huge as our stage,
the horse can be very happy.
FEMALE SPEAKER: That sounds like
a pretty nice life for a horse.
NORMAND LATOURELLE: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: How is it that
you rotate horses on and off,
the ones who have proven
themselves at least?
NORMAND LATOURELLE:
Well, in Odysseo, we
have almost 70 horses touring.
And in Cavalia,
we have 40 horses.
And the company owns about
200 of them in total.
So we have a farm in Canada,
and we just supply horses.
And some horses,
most of the horse
will not stay longer than
four years or five years.
Not because they're tired,
they just get bored.
And we want to give them
some pasture at one point.
They like to eat greens.
And when you're on tour,
they have paddocks outside.
Even in downtown San
Jose, they have paddocks.
But it's not the most
comfortable paddock.
They look at the greens
and there's only sand.
So it's good for them.
It's good for their
[? mental ?] to go to pasture.
So after four years,
if they're young horses
and happy performers, we
remove them for two years
and bring them back.
And we have a team,
a complete team
that is taking care of
the renewal of the horse
but also the people.
Because sometimes,
we hired acrobats
who knew nothing about horses,
because we have a cast of 45.
Half of them are acrobat
bases and the other half
are horse riders,
trainers based.
So we have to teach
the horse riders
how to become acrobats and
the opposite way around.
Some of the acrobats have to
learn how to be with horses.
And we like to have
multi-skilled humans,
but we also like to have
multi-skilled horses, which
is very unique in our world.
Because everyone who has a
horse knows that the horse
will ride a certain way.
If he's riding English saddle,
he's riding English saddle.
If he's riding Western
saddle, it's Western saddle.
If you have a jumping horse,
that's all he does-- he jumps.
But our horses, we
try to bring them
to three different disciplines,
which makes them even more
happy, because every time
they come in the show,
they don't know what
we're going to do.
So it's just bringing their
mind to something different.
I compare often horses to
kids, three year old kids.
More or less two and a
half, three years old.
So especially boys,
they're very unpredictable.
I say that because
I had two boys.
So they're very unpredictable.
And the horses are
the same thing.
But if you bring
something to them
that lit and makes them
want to play and be happy,
you have your best
friend in the world.
FEMALE SPEAKER: What is a day
in the life of these horses?
NORMAND LATOURELLE: They have
six meals a day, mostly hay.
We like to give them hay during
the entire day, because it
keeps them occupied.
Again, you just have
to reproduce what they
are in the field or in nature.
So we're trying always to-- if
you see a horse in the field,
you rarely see a horse head up.
Always down, looking for
little bits and bites of grass.
So we feed them six times a day.
And that starts very
early in the morning.
Because horses,
they do sleep down,
for the ones who don't know.
They do sleep down, but never
more than 40, 45 minutes,
and then they go up.
And it's also very
interesting to watch them,
because when one goes
down, the next one
stays up, because
he's checking to make
sure everything is fine.
And then when this
one will go up,
this one will go down for
40 minutes, but not longer
than 40 minutes, because
they need to eat.
Because they eat grass.
It's like us if we eat
only salad all day long.
I promise you, you will eat
at least 10 meals a day.
And the horse is the same thing,
because they eat only grass.
And then riders arrive.
So they get groomed
and all that.
And then the riders
arrive, or the trainer
arrives at about
10:00 in the morning.
And the horses rotate.
They go outside every
day for one hour.
And then they do 40 minutes of
just warming up, just walking
or running.
Mostly free.
And later during the day,
they do probably half an hour
of real training, what they
are best at, or their skills.
And before the show, they get
20 minutes of warm-up again,
and then they do the show.
Average of stay for a
horse on stage, the average
is about 10 minutes.
Some people ask me if
horses are intelligent.
Obviously, compared
to humans, based
on the number of hours
they work during the day,
they're very intelligent.
[LAUGHTER]
FEMALE SPEAKER: I
can appreciate that.
Absolutely.
So when the riders are
working with them, or maybe
not even necessarily riders,
but especially the liberty
portions, where the
horses are free, just
following their person, how do
you train a horse to do that?
NORMAND LATOURELLE: Most
of the regular people
who are not working
in the horse world,
like you have horses,
I know you have horses,
but you have to work.
And you have to sleep.
And then you spend maybe
three or four hours
with your horse a week.
Our trainers spend 10 hours
a day with their horses.
And we have the luxury of time.
So that's why we don't
push them for training.
We just wait for
them to be ready.
We're slowly training them.
And then you start to
create a real bond.
And there's one part
in the show that you
have about 40 horses free.
And you have eight
people just leading them.
And this is the
most amazing part,
because it's like a ballet.
It's hard to explain.
And they have no ropes, nothing.
And the horses just
follow their trainer.
They follow the trainer
because they like the trainer.
It's their friend, and this
is why that's happening.
And people from the
horse world look at this
and say how the hell
have you done that?
It is difficult to
do it with one horse.
To get followed by a horse,
if you walk in the field
or in the paddock, to make sure
that the horse is following
you, it's an achievement.
So we have 40 of them
following eight people, which
is absolutely spectacular.
And it's very beautiful.
And this is where you can
notice that the horses are
happy to do it.
Because they just follow.
They're their friends.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Are there
little bits of carrots
in their pocket?
NORMAND LATOURELLE:
Good question.
The answer is, no.
We do give carrots,
but after they
have done what they had to do.
Otherwise, the horse
will just ask for it,
which will not be funny.
And also, if you give too much
carrot to the horses that work
or is that work-- we call it "at
work"-- when he comes on stage,
he will just have his
mind set for carrots.
For us to reward a
horse with carrots,
we just thank him
at the end and he
knows we're happy with
what he has achieved.
So he's not there asking, but
we do have a lot of carrots
backstage in the stable.
I don't know how much
we spend in carrots,
but it's a big budget.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I
can believe that.
So the horses are unpredictable,
although they're trained.
The audience, I would think,
is even more unpredictable.
How do you deal
with anything that
comes up with the
audience or something that
is out of your control?
NORMAND LATOURELLE:
Well, we give not
carrots but we give
popcorn to the audience.
Better control.
Since we are doing Odysseo,
since the first show--
that was five years ago.
We're about to be five
years old in October--
I don't know how many thousands
of performances we've done,
but I have not seen one show
where the audience doesn't
stand up at the end of the show.
And this is a gift
for a creator to see
at the end of every performance
2,000 people or whatever there
is, because there's 2,000
seats whatever there is,
in the audience standing
up and applauding.
And I see people
crying and how they're
laughing and being happy.
So that's why I do that.
I'm just trying to bring
a little bit of happiness
on this earth.
And you can see people
have enjoyed this show.
And I can say after touring
it for so many years,
I can say-- this might
sound pretentious,
but that's probably
one of the best
shows that exist on the planet.
You have to experience it.
Because people will say,
oh, it's a horse show.
I'm not a horse person.
It doesn't matter.
It's just a feel-good show.
It's a good show that
will elevate your spirit.
FEMALE SPEAKER: It made
me happy-- very happy.
NORMAND LATOURELLE: Good.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Does anyone have
any questions in the audience
they want to ask?
AUDIENCE: Which is the
favorite breed of horses?
Because I noticed some
Arabians out there,
which I happen to have one.
So which is the favorite,
smartest, easiest to teach?
NORMAND LATOURELLE:
You know, it depends
on what you ask them to do.
For the Arabians, we
have a lot of Arabians
because we do what
we call liberty.
And there are very playful.
That's why we like them.
And also, they like
to stay in herds
more than the other horses.
They are very inclined
to be part of a group.
So when we do
liberty, at one point,
there's about 12 horses coming.
it depends on the
show, from 8 to 12.
But they all behave together,
and they all act together,
and they're totally free.
And there's one girl.
Her name is Elise Verdoncq.
She's the main trainer
for those horses.
And also, I think
they're very elegant.
And the Arabian,
for the ones who
don't know, when they
start to be happy,
it's a little bit like
the dogs with the tails,
but the tail goes up.
And it's very nice.
They're very beautiful, very
elegant, and light horses.
So they can just
achieve, like, a waltz.
I see it like a waltz.
So that's why we have
a lot of Arabians.
But that having been
said, are they easier
to train than other horses?
I don't think so.
I think the easiest
horses to train,
obviously, are the
American quarter
horses, because they are cold.
We call it "cold-blood."
They're a little bit colder and
really nothing affects them.
And you can see why
the cowboys used
to shoot guns over
a quarter horse,
because he's just
like, yeah, OK.
Something is going on.
Where, if you do that with
an Arabian, I'm telling you,
he's away as far as he could.
So that's why.
So the Arabians like
to have movement,
and that's why we have a
lot for this liberty part.
AUDIENCE: What's the ideal age
that you'll introduce horses
to the program?
Will you take two, three
year-olds that are newly broke?
Will you take a
16 year-old horse
that's been doing something
else his whole life?
What do you tend to aim for
with the age of your horses?
NORMAND LATOURELLE:
Yeah, very good question.
First, we don't breed horses.
We buy horses that are
already fully-- conformated?
Con-- con-- con-- what?
AUDIENCE: Conformed.
NORMAND LATOURELLE: Conformed.
I'm sorry.
Looking for the word.
Fully conformed
so we know what we
buy, so we know how he
looks, how he'll behave.
So usually, we rarely buy
horses under three years old.
Most likely, we like to
buy them at four or five,
but with the minimum of being
what you call in English
"broken."
I don't like this word,
but that's the word we use.
So minimally ridden
but not too much.
Because if you take
a horse that has
been trained by
somebody too difficult,
then you have a difficult horse.
So that's why we try to buy
them around four or five.
We will sometimes
find an exception
of a six, seven years old horse,
but we don't keep them on tour.
There's no horses
over-- right now,
I think the oldest is
16 or 17 years old.
And we still have some
horses that were there
in Cavalia, actually, in 2003.
One of the first horses I
bought is a quarter horse.
His name is Choice,
and he's at the farm.
And when they used to
go there more often,
a couple years ago, I
used to do hamburgers.
And he was coming
next to me, because he
was free on the farm.
So he was helping
me with hamburgers.
But no, these horses can live.
When they leave the tour, it's
not because they are finished.
It's just because it's
time for them to leave.
After 16, 17 years old, we find
them either an adoption place,
or we bring them to our farm.
AUDIENCE: I think
over the past 30 years
or so the Quebecois circus,
from Cirque du Soleil to Cavalia
to Odysseo, has really
reshaped that whole genre.
Why do you think that is?
What have you seen change
from the early days to now?
NORMAND LATOURELLE: Yeah, this
is a very difficult question
to answer.
How you define-- how
come-- and it's true.
When you travel around the world
and you see the entertainment,
live entertainment
world, you see
a lot of people from
Quebec, like my province,
like from Montreal and Quebec.
Why is that?
I cannot the answer.
Maybe it's something
in the water.
I don't know what it is,
to tell you the truth.
That having been
said, we are a mix
of-- I consider myself a mix
of American and European.
And that's probably that we get
the influence of both worlds.
And because we're a very
small, tiny French community--
we're only three million
people over that ocean
of English speakers--
we probably
have developed some skills of
fighting and trying to express
ourselves differently.
That's maybe one of the reasons.
And I was there for the
beginning of Cirque.
And after Cirque, as you know
now, I've started Cavalia.
And I think behind
me and other people
is the idea of to trying to
do something new, different,
and push the limits.
That's probably what it is.
That's what it is
for me, actually.
AUDIENCE: When you're
doing live performances,
is there a guideline
or rule of thumb,
particularly during
the liberty portions,
where if one of the
horses is not cooperating,
someone will remove the
horse from the stage?
Or will you always
just keep going
and trying to bring the horse
back into the performance?
NORMAND LATOURELLE:
Most of the time,
we try to bring them
back to the performance.
It did that happen.
It did happen.
It could happen that
if a horse really
started to be-- because we
have a lot of stallions.
We have only male horses, and
we have a lot of stallions.
So if a stallion starts to
behave very badly, which
could happen, at the
time, we will take a rope,
bring him out.
But that happens very rarely.
Most of the time, we
let them, what I call,
express themselves.
And after a while,
because I've seen horses
running for three minutes, and
running and kicking and having
fun.
So the rule is, let him.
If he's not dangerous for
the horses, let him do it.
And after two or three
minutes, he's just--
[PANTING]
OK, what do I do now?
And then he's coming back.
This is nature.
This is so easy.
You just have to read it.
And it's also very interesting,
because I repeat that
to whoever is next to horses,
probably because I'm not
next to horses I can say it.
I say to the people, the
horses never makes mistakes.
It's the human who
makes mistakes.
It's just changing
the perspective.
You ask something to the horse.
If he doesn't do it, it's
because you didn't ask right,
or you didn't take the time
to let him answer right.
And that's the
philosophy behind it.
But it's easy to say for me.
But for the trainers,
some of the girls
are five feet four
inches next to a horse
that is twice her size.
I can see sometimes, OK,
that's a nice philosophy
but it's a big animal.
It's a question of balance.
I think it's always--
that's in life.
Everything in life for me,
it's a question of balance.
It's the same thing.
Next to an animal, even
more, next to any animal,
it's a question of balance.
If you want to dominate too
much, he won't like you.
If you want to be his
friend, he will like you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: What
was your childhood like?
How did your parents
influence you?
And if your mother
was here, what would
she say was the first sign that
you would be who you are today?
NORMAND LATOURELLE: Oh,
that's a moving question,
because my mother just passed
away about eight months ago.
And my mother, even if I was
doing very stupid and crazy
things when I was young,
which my father didn't like,
but my mother
always supported me.
And probably my mother
gave me the courage,
as far as my idea,
of bringing me to.
Because I'm one of the rare
guys who has the two votes.
I'm producing the show.
So financially, I'm
involved, and I'm creating
the show, which is very rare.
Usually, you see
someone who'll create
and you find someone who brings
the money in and produces.
I have the two.
The reason why I'm
like that, probably
is because nobody at first when
I started to talk about, I'm
going to do a great show with
horses, they were looking at me
like-- and if you
go to a producer
or whoever has
money to tell him,
I'm going to do a
great show with horses,
it's going to be very modern.
And 10 years ago,
people just don't come.
So I said, OK, I'm going
to support my idea.
The reality is the producer
suffers more than the creator
because I'm spending
so much money.
But I am just pushing my
idea as far as I could.
And that's probably
from my mother.
And because it's become very
personal, also in my family,
my oldest brother is disabled.
And I've been very
supportive of him.
Even today, he's
66 67 right now.
Very supportive of
him, but I always
felt I was very blessed
compared to him.
And I always felt,
even when I was young,
I had to do twice
more because he
couldn't do what he deserved.
And I just always
pushed the limit.
It's probably the
combination of two.
I like to say I was
born on a sidewalk.
I passed my young
age in an alley.
And I became a
teenager in the street.
That's probably how
to resume my life.
And then when I grew up, I
just traveled around the world.
That's who I am.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I noticed
in the teaser clip,
there was a pool of water.
And some of the horses were
going through the water
and the acrobats were
jumping through the water.
Do you actually have
a pool on stage?
And does that
introduce other kinds
of difficulties or challenges?
NORMAND LATOURELLE: Definitely,
a lot of challenges.
We fill the stage.
Again, the stage is about
the size of a hockey rink.
We filled it in about
one minute, 30 seconds
with 40,000 gallons of water.
Again, this is a touring show.
It's very complicated, because
we change location everywhere
we go.
So it has to be totally level.
Because if it's
not level, you know
what happens with the water.
So it's very challenging.
And it's one of the most
technically challenging parts
of the show.
But I thought I wanted--
Odysseo is-- let's say the word.
It's an odyssey,
where men and horses
go to discover the most
beautiful landscape
in the world.
So they're just
traveling together.
That's why I call it odyssey.
And in the end, "eau" is
because of the water coming.
And I think you cannot-- and
the stage reveals a lot about
nature.
So you cannot reveal about
nature without talking about
the water, which is
the source of life,
which is also
where animals meet.
If you go to anywhere, the
animals, every kind of animal,
meet, including humans,
around a source of water.
And I could not
do a show talking
about the relationship
of men and horses
and traveling throughout the
world without having water,
even if it's very challenging.
Because this show, again,
you have to see it,
but it's the biggest
touring show in the world.
We have about 120 semi
trailers when we move.
If you compare to the biggest
rock 'n' roll tour, the Rolling
Stones or U2, they have only 65.
I mean, it's a big tour.
And the big tent
is one of a kind,
because I didn't want to
have the feeling of a circus.
I'm not a circus guy,
where you see the ring
and everything goes around.
I didn't want that.
So we really created a space
that is like a real auditorium.
And people are sitting in the
auditorium, like here, facing
the stage, but the
stage is very, very big.
And there's no obstruction.
Most of the tents you see in
the world, even the Cirque du
Soleil tents, the big one, you
see a mast next to the stage.
When you get to see Odysseo,
you see no obstruction.
There's no mast.
Everything is
supported by-- if you
pass nearby the tent over
there, you see three arches.
We support 80 tons of equipment
there but with these arches.
So if you're into engineering,
just go and watch carefully.
It's a marvel of engineering.
This is just an amazing
engineering piece.
Because when you tour, rock
'n' roll tour in an arena,
usually the maximum weight they
put to the ceiling is 50 tons.
And we have 80.
One of the most important
elements of the show
is a merry-go-round that
appears from the ceiling.
Again, you're under a tent.
You're not in a
permanent theater.
And the merry-go-round is
very big, weighs 18 tons.
And we do an
acrobatic act on it.
And this part, I
mean, you've seen it.
It's just magical and
brings you to a dream world.
Again, this is because I pushed
the idea and made it happen.
That's the thing-- you just have
an idea and you make it happen.
So whatever it costs, is it
possible or not, let's do it.
And that's what is defining,
pretty much, Odysseo.
AUDIENCE: You have
dozens of horses.
Do you ever acquire horses
as your show is traveling?
Because, I mean,
you're in places where
there's horse communities or?
NORMAND LATOURELLE: Yeah.
Yeah, we do, actually.
Yeah, we do.
We have horses--
yesterday, I was
talking to one of
the grooms, and we
have one horse from
Australia, because Cavalia
went to Australia.
And after a while, we
brought the horse back
to North America.
And he's now touring
with Odysseo.
And we have horses from Arizona,
because we were in Arizona.
We have horses from California.
And we always look
for good horses.
And they are everywhere.
There's no specific place
where we buy horses.
But of course we have
a lot of-- again,
I just might repeat here, but
we have a lot of Spanish horses.
So these ones, of course,
we go to buy them in Spain.
But other than that, we buy
through the course of the tour.
AUDIENCE: All right, two
more quick questions.
Which market have you
made the most money in
or is most popular, where
you have the most response?
And have you ever thought
of having a permanent show,
like a permanent building?
NORMAND LATOURELLE: Yeah.
Well, there's a big difference
between Cavalia and Odysseo.
Cavalia made money.
Odysseo is spending money.
That's why it's worth
it for you to go
see how do you spend money.
With no joking, California is
a very good, very good market.
We were in San
Francisco not long ago.
We did fantastic.
We just arrived a couple
months ago from Irvine.
We're returning to Irvine.
So California is a great market.
Also, in terms of economies,
which is very important, when
you are into entertainment, live
entertainment in California,
you don't pay tax, which
I mean, on the ticket.
If you go back where I
live, you pay 15% of tax.
So it does make
a big difference.
AUDIENCE: It's the only
thing we're not taxed on.
NORMAND LATOURELLE: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: It's the one thing in
California you're not taxed on!
NORMAND LATOURELLE:
Well, yeah, exactly.
I mean, you have other taxes.
I don't say you
don't have taxes.
I just say, we're not
taxed, because we're
live entertainment, which is
fantastic, which is fantastic.
So in terms of business,
doing business in California
is very good for us.
Where we stayed the longest?
Actually, we return many
times so it's hard to say.
But Cavalia, the first
show is now in China.
It has been performing in
Beijing for six months,
and we are still extending.
So this is a revelation, because
we don't know-- we didn't know.
And there's no horses in China.
There's very, very little.
There's a lot of horses in
their culture, a lot of horses
in their mythology.
But the reality is there's
not that many horses in China.
Very little unless
you go far north.
So that having been said,
the first show for whoever
has seen it, the
first show there's
two small horses that
open the first act.
And here we see horses.
We applaud, and it's the
beginning of the show.
Over there, they're like kids.
I'm talking about the audience.
You hear "woooo!" every show.
It's surprising, because
they don't see live horses.
You're in the middle of Beijing.
I don't know if any of
you have been to Beijing,
but it's a monstrous city.
I mean, San Francisco
and Los Angeles
are very small
compared to Beijing.
So that's where we
spend a lot of time.
And of course,
Montreal, my hometown,
I mean, when we go
there, we're big stars.
At least one city we're a big
star in the world, my own city!
We do very good
business in Canada too.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My question is,
can you comment a little bit
on the logistics?
You have 120 trailers
that are going around?
NORMAND LATOURELLE: Yeah,
semi-trailers for Odysseo.
AUDIENCE: I'm just
trying to imagine
all the people that you need.
You have 45 performers,
I think you mentioned.
You've got people that have
to take care of the horses.
You need people to set up
the tents, the lighting,
the orchestra, the
musicians, all that.
How many people are
touring with you?
And how do you handle
all these logistics?
NORMAND LATOURELLE: Yeah.
We have 120-- I was going
to say 120 semi-trailers.
That's true.
But 120 permanent staff
touring with us full time.
We run the show at
about 200 people.
So the 80 people every
day are local people.
When we set up, when we
move, because we move
this big tour in about 17 days,
from the last show in a city
to the first show in the next
city, and then we are about 200
per day, about 200 to 250
people per day to help
to set up and dismantle.
The logistics, I guess
we get used to it.
We have fantastic people
taking care of all the details.
There's a lot to be done.
There's a lot to achieve.
I guess it's a little
bit like the army.
When it's time to move,
you just back your truck
and you just move and
set up in the next city.
And it's also
personal logistics.
Because everyone
lives in an apartment.
But you know what it is.
When you tour, you
start with one luggage,
and then you have two,
three, four, five.
There's a rider who
left us yesterday
after five years of touring.
She went back home.
And she said, I don't know
how I'm going to do it.
I have seven luggage.
And I said, oh, I don't
think Air Canada will
accept seven luggage from you.
But the reality is, we
have to have a container,
and we call it an extra
luggage container.
And it's all part of what we do.
And it's mainly because we have
very good people who do it.
AUDIENCE: There are many really
magical parts of your show.
One of the parts that was most
astounding, as someone who's
ridden horses, was
there's a trick rider who
goes under the belly of the
horse and back up to the top
while the horse is galloping.
Can you tell me
a little bit more
about how long they've
trained for that?
I've never seen anything
like that before.
That was just amazing.
Or where that trick came from?
NORMAND LATOURELLE:
Well, this number,
we call it Cossack riding.
And it's from the
far part of Russia.
They've started this type
of riding over there.
And there are very few
guys who are doing it,
but the reality, if
you look carefully,
the horse that does it is
very tall, and this guy
has enough space to move.
But you have to
establish a real trust,
because nobody is
riding the horse.
He's just going full
speed and around.
You don't want to
stop, or him to stop.
You don't want him to slow down.
So they get to train him, and
finally he goes under the belly
and comes back after every show.
And it's very
spectacular, very scary.
My hands get wet every
time I see him doing it.
Will I do it?
No.
But he's an athlete and that's
what he does for a living,
believe it or not.
But it's very impressive.
And the show brings you to
a lot of action sometimes.
And sometimes, it's
very smooth, beautiful.
And this show brings
you to a lot of-- it's
just a feel-good show.
After the show, I say, wow.
I've seen something different.
I've seen something that
animals [? live ?] well.
They seem happy.
And it's just a
beautiful show, I think.
And you just said it,
but I like to repeat it.
Because there's nothing
harsh in this show.
There's nothing that
you can say, "ohhh."
It's just beautiful.
That's the idea behind it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you so
much for being here today.
NORMAND LATOURELLE: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]